okay you lied now
thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to this latest meeting of the
trafford coal big 19 public engagement
board
i have apologies this morning from ben
wilmot who was unfortunately succumbed
to covid
so helen will be giving his update on
mass testing
um
clearly a lot's happened uh in in the
last few days with the government
announcements today's meeting
will be focusing on reassurance
following the government's announcements
on monday and i know that helen is going
to present some slides to us on the way
forward
there are some alterations to the agenda
as well and we welcome back uh bini
shanee who's going to give us an update
on care homes and supported
accommodation and also ali khannak has
joined us this morning to talk about the
future of the government the common
strategy going forward i can tell you
now at the start of the meeting our next
meeting will be wednesday the 16th of
march at 10 a.m which if you could make
a note of that now for your diaries and
that will probably be the last meeting
of the public engagement board and the
focus of that meeting will be on living
with kovid in trafford going forward so
um moving to the agenda now
are there any further apologies this
morning from anybody
no i don't see any thank you uh any
declarations of interest in the in any
of the
items on the agenda
i don't see that either thank you and
the minutes of the meeting on the 9th of
february can they be taken as a true and
accurate record and taken as read
yeah agree with that
and so we move on to the update and the
current situation and welcome helen
collins good morning helen
thank you chair so i i've got a couple
of things just to talk you through um
one is the current epidemiology for
trafford and then i've got a couple of
slides about the announcements on monday
so there's some timelines in there just
to make you all aware of um the next
steps and then just some key messages
for from the local team really but my
colleagues are here from all the
different work plans programs this
morning in the covered response so can
give you a fuller update um as they talk
through as well so just to let you know
things are looking better in trafford um
we are have a rate of 277 per 100 000 in
terms of positive cases up until friday
the 18th of february so in numbers terms
that's 659 local residents who tested
positive in those seven days that's a um
a drop again in our rates so the
comparative period is 426 per hundred
thousand so you can see a really you
know steady decline there
the rate was roughly about the same uh
in july 2021 so that gives you an
indication of um how it's kind of
compares to our other waves and and
other kind of element areas of the
pandemic as well
our rates far over 60s remain at 205 per
100 thousand again that's declined which
is really good to see
um and our positivity so the proportion
of people who test positive for covid um
is really low now is looking good at
nine percent of people who attend for a
test
we're the second highest in greater
manchester um stockport is the highest
in terms of boroughs uh their rate is at
two eight eight per hundred thousand and
there isn't a huge difference between
all ten wards uh ten boroughs at the
moment
and they're all decreasing as well which
is great to see
um in terms of where in trafford our
rates um are the highest we're currently
highest in brooklyn ashton upon mersey
hale barnes priory and saint mary's so
you can see that's very much down in the
south and central area of the um
at the borough but i think it's
important just to note that as the
numbers become smaller it becomes more
volatile and the wards do kind of bounce
around a little bit there
in terms of age groups again which is
really good to see all our age groups
have decreased including our five to
nines where we had seen a lot of
activity in the first half term the rate
is highest at the moment but not you
know notably higher in the 30 to 44 year
olds when we were thinking that through
we're thinking is that people who are
out and about workplace and socializing
and are continuing to test is
symptomatic so that's potentially why
we're seeing that within the age group
but again nothing alarming in any of the
age groups at the moment
recognizing that we are on half term at
the moment um
and i know that as a parent myself half
term seem to be scattered across a
number of different weeks this time and
so we will be watching as an outbreak
team um
any activity in our schools going
forward when they return i think it's
next monday a lot of the trafford
schools return some have returned this
week as well
in terms of reinfection no change in
terms of patterns of reinfection our
rates of reinfection remain highest in
the north of the borough and the west of
the borough as well
hospital activities decreased so um
up to the week ending sunday the 3rd of
february this is for the all of greater
manchester
from all the 10 boys in greater
manchester into the greater manchester
hospitals there were 212 covert related
emissions and this is a decline from 238
for the comparative period so all going
in the right direction
and um
it's the same for our deaths we have
seen a decrease in the number of people
who suddenly die as a result of covid so
that's in terms of our epi um molly are
you able to
just share the slides that i sent
thank you
thanks so this is just i've just taken
some key kind of um messages really
could you put them a slide um view
thank you from the guidance it was
released late on monday evening and just
to share with you really um sorry molly
i'm being really demanding could you
just make it a little bit smaller so it
all fits on the screen
that'd be really helpful
we'll go with that that's fine um so you
can see there's four prior four kind of
principles underpinning the government's
announcement they're living with covid
so that's removal of the domestic
restrictions protecting the most
vulnerable
uh maintaining resilience and that's
about um surveillance and contingency
planning and securing innovation and
opportunities from the covered 19
response so that's around looking back
seeing what worked and what didn't work
we are doing some work on that locally
in trafford as well uh in terms of
looking at our silver response and gold
response that's a really useful exercise
if you go on to the next slide molly
so this is the information really that
will interest you the most and this is
the timeline of when
when the different restrictions and
different policy changes come into
effect
so from the 21st of february you'll see
that the guidance
has been removed for testing of staff
and students in most education and child
care settings
from the 24th which is tomorrow people
who have tested positive for covered no
are no longer required to isolate
um but the recommendation is still that
if you do test positive for covid you
you do isolate and you test on day five
but you're not required to isolate so
there's just a bit of nuance there in
the language
um the workers are not legally obliged
to tell their employees if they're
required to self-isolate routine contact
tracing will end
um
fully vaccinated close contacts and
those under 18 no longer need to test
for seven days if there are contact and
equally if you are a close contact and
you're not fully vaccinated you don't
need to self-isolate and then the health
protection regulations are going to be
revoked as well
from the 24th of march you'll see that
the provision of statutory sick pay and
employment and support allowances will
end and in the first of april um
you'll see that new guidance will be
issued from the government in terms of
minimizing contact if you are positive
um health and safety requirements for
every employer to explicitly consider
covered in risk assessments will be
removed
working safely guidance will um be
reshaped into general public health
guidance and there will no longer be a
free universal symptomatic or
asymptomatic testing to the general
public in england and i think the
important bits here are um
there will be limited ongoing free
testing so there's limited symptomatic
testing available for a small number of
at-risk groups our understanding around
this at the moment is it's for over 75
and those people who are exceptionally
clinically vulnerable as well and then
there will be free symptomatic testing
for um people in social care uh social
care stuff as well so that's the the
timeline that we're working to at the
moment
and molly if you um but yeah if you
could just move on to the next slide
so these are some key kind of um
mitigations in a way that that are
included in the um guidance so i just
wanted to reassure pebb that although
for some people it might feel
um
very quick that everything is changing
but there are lots of kind of safeguards
in place for us as a locality and as you
know nationally locally and regionally
as well so i just wanted to reassure
colleagues around this
so vaccination will still be and is a
priority is one of our you know many um
kind of
interventions that really do work
against covert so we will continue to
really support the vaccination programme
and you'll have seen on monday the
announcement of a booster for um our
over 75s and other vulnerable groups as
well so we would really um support
our residents um that as soon as they
are eligible for that booster spring
booster then do take it and also would
reiterate i'm sure jilla will speak
about this um just about ensuring if
you've not yet had your first second or
your booster and you are really thinking
about it then do do go forward do find
um a vaccination center and do have your
vaccine
um so we in terms of vaccination um
nationally there's still going to be a
continued kind of program of vaccination
and locally we'll be working with our
ccg and nhs colleagues to ensure um
opportunities across the borough to
provide vaccination and then our data
teams will also be
looking at the data monitoring the data
and really looking at any inequality and
working to address the inequalities
our outbreak management hub which is led
by kirsty catherine's here today um will
continue to work closely with the
greater manchester system
um
we will we are working at the moment
looking at the shift from the population
response so how we've worked across the
whole of our population to our complex
settings as well and we're awaiting
guidance on complex settings
and then what we what we've also
committed to as well is because we've
had really strong relationships with our
early years in education
settings throughout the pandemic is that
we will
still remain and they can still access
us and ask us any questions or any
support with any kind of scenarios that
they might have um for the time being
within the guidance there is a statement
to say that ppe free ppe will be
available until march 2023 so that's
really positive to see
treatment so obviously we're a long way
on than where we were when we started
with the pandemic we didn't fully
understand the virus um we didn't um
have the vaccine but now we have
antivirals and we have therapeutics and
what um we're waiting for is further
guidance for our nhs colleagues and pcm
colleagues and we'll work together as a
system to understand that guidance but
also just to let members know that
people who have been identified as
having particular specific immune
conditions have all been sent a specific
pcr test that if they become symptomatic
they can take the pcr really quickly
it's turned around incredibly quickly in
the labs and then this means that they
can access the antivirals within the um
desired time period so with antivirals
often it's within 72 hours that you have
to take them so that's a really good
kind of protective approach we have
there for some of our very vulnerable um
residents
adult social care vaccination guidance
for visitors and workers and free ppe
was is still very much part of the
approach uh coming out of the pandemic
and just to reassure colleagues on pep
that we've got some really really strong
networks with our care homes and our
supported accommodation and our home
care providers we work closely with them
with our infection prevention and
control team and with our outbreak hub
um and bienish is going to talk a little
bit about that in the moment but that's
just to assure you there in terms of our
complex settings and finally um
surveillance will continue uh uxa who
were public health england who are now
the uk health security agency will
continue to maintain critical
surveillance so when we're thinking and
obviously people will be feeling um
a little bit anxious around uh issues
around variants but uxo will be taking
the lead on this and we have really
strong working relationships with ux
uh molly could you go into the next
slide please
so also in their guidance is very much
around communications and i'm going to
leave um the detailed elements of this
to
ellie but i guess as director of public
health and as a locality team we very
much
would recommend our residents and
colleagues and and our leaders to really
continue to live by the coveted rules um
you know the vaccination program is
absolutely a priority ventilation is
crucial i know it's been chilly and
maybe some of us with the winds have had
more ventilation than we'd
hoped for but ventilation is really
important in the workplace
and if you're having visitors
face coverings you know continue to wear
face coverings in crowded and enclosed
areas
and that's something that we would um
very much support
stay at home if you feel unwell and take
a test if you have covered symptoms
and then finally the really important
thing for any respiratory or infectious
disease is around hand washing and
if you know you have a cough or cold
catch it bin it kill it and hand wash is
really really important
so that just some key bits there that i
wanted to share with you molly if you
couldn't share the screen
so the key messages are what we would as
a locality team and as director of
public health really share with you but
i just wanted to also share with you our
locality response for the next 12 months
so we will still have a covered response
team similar to what we have had a
little bit more streamlined but this is
to support us with any ongoing covered
response that may be required to plan
into autumn winter before we recognize
you know autumn winter
um 2022 and 2023 may be a challenge
um we haven't seen the flu activity that
we would usually see
um so it's about preparedness for
any increased flu activity as well
so the response team will continue
to provide oversight and support to our
partners and to our residents
and also our data team as well will
continue to work on really looking at
the data what it's telling us and
working with our nhs partners as well
and finally we as a system as a locality
we are committed to the health and
well-being of our residents but also
very much uh working closely with our
partners at gm and national just to
understand the landscape and obviously
how things are very different now
following the pandemic and how we can
all live safely with covid so thank you
thank you very much helen uh i think a
lot of that was extremely reassuring uh
are there any questions at all
yesterday council
yeah
thanks for that presentation i think it
was really useful and helpful um
yeah it's just about the uh vaccinations
really and i know that you you mentioned
the fourth vaccination
um that
people over 75 and vulnerable people can
can have
other plans moving forward
in the summer maybe or in in in the
autumn that there'll be
um
you know an annual
uh vaccination
um as we have with flu
um
or you know what are the things what
what's the thinking around the
vaccinations going forward
thanks council acton from us from our
perspective we haven't received any
guidance yet in terms of um kind of what
we would describe as a business as usual
vaccine schedule
and so we're waiting guidance on that
but i'm going to hand over to my
colleagues mark and to jilla
because they are very much more kind of
engrossed in the vaccination program
so
um if i can come in there at the moment
the jcvi is saying that there is likely
to be
um
a spring booster
and
an autumn booster
for at least the over 75s and the
clinical vulnerable clinically
vulnerable
but i'm afraid that's about as far as
the detail goes at this point in time
um
so you know i i can't tell you any more
than that
um yes you know it's been reported in
the mainstream press and and that's as
much detail as we have
the
how we're going to
work that
and what the dates expected dates are
going to be i'm still not quite sure
yeah i mean i think um
you know with the announcement from
government you would have thought that
you know that that would go hand in hand
in terms of how we move forward
um you know living with um you know
covid um
which is fine you know we have to do
that at some point but you'd think that
there would be some kind of
announcement around
you know
the future vaccination programs i'm sure
there are people who actually you know
think about these things and know about
these things i'm sure you do as well so
but you know every weekly embedded and
asking us questions like that through
the throughout the whole of the pandemic
response the operational detail has
always lagged
uh a little bit bit behind the uh
government announcements
and i think i'll leave it at that
yeah no i appreciate that i think that's
very diplomatically put mark um
i've got a question now from councillor
new grosjean and then i'll bring julia
in thank you thank you for that um so i
just want to be how confident are we of
the we've got everyone in the clinically
vulnerable group have we got mechanisms
for moving people into it that we might
have missed
so i think i was going to say mark was
probably yeah i'm probably best to
answer that because it's
um
people are picked up automatically
through the coded data entries on their
gp system
uh effectively so if we get a new
diagnosis
that new diagnosis is entered onto your
gp summary
and as soon as that
coded
entry is made
it links into the system to make you
eligible and flag you up for those
vaccinations as required
so as long as we've got good data entry
we will be picking those people up
appropriately i and yeah you raise your
eyes but but across trafford i can
assure you we've got good quality
general practice who are doing that
thank you thank you mark gillard
thank you yes i was just going to add
one additional point in response to
councillor acton's query about the
future booster programs
you're right we anticipate that
announcement but i want to reassure you
that while we anticipate the
announcement the planning is underway
for a winter vaccination program at gm
level and to say that the likelihood is
that that would be aligned as far as
possible with the
uh winter flu vaccination program but as
helen and mark say um the detail is not
yet there
oh thanks
thank you
any further questions at all
i don't see any so
helen do you want to give us an update
on mass testing in the absence of of ben
who of course we wish a speedy recovery
too
yeah poor ben um let me sorry let me
just find his notes he sent me
there they are so ben says new testing
guidance
as of monday uh staff and students in
most education settings no longer have
to test twice weekly stuff from pupils
and specialists send settings
alternative provision and send units in
mainstream schools are advised to
continue to regularly twice weekly tests
from tomorrow which is the 24th under
18s and fully vaccinated close contacts
don't don't need to take daily tests
from the first of april provision of
free universal symptomatic and
asymptomatic testing will end
symptomatic testing will remain for
social care and healthcare staff but
we're awaiting further details on this
as well as this the older stage groups
which we believe are the over 80s and
the most vulnerable presumed to be
extremely clinically vulnerable will
also be able to get free tests if
they're symptomatic
key messages so from although from
tomorrow there's no legal requirement to
self-isolate the key national message is
that if you have covert symptoms you
should avoid contact with others and
order a pcr test if you test positive
you should stay at home
also if you can still take lfds if
you're going out and about especially
visiting vulnerable people lfds can be
obtained online or at the national
portal
and from our library so that's stratford
ernst sale partington and altringham and
obviously we wish ben a speedy recovery
thank you very much for that helen um
we'll move on to um contact uh tracing
and outbreak management and uh i
invite catherine to address us thank you
catherine
thank you chair okay so over in the
outbreak and contact tracing hub we
continue to work with our schools in
early early years settings and our
priority remains to be to keep children
in education in face-to-face um
currently the
rates look rather low as helen mentioned
quite a few of our traffic schools have
been on half term but we've currently
got cases in nine primary schools six
secondary schools and eleven early year
settings and none of those settings we
were considered to be an outbreak at the
moment
um our education settings continue to
have really excellent communication with
which we thank them for
um
we are also seeing really low activity
in our business settings at current but
again communication remains really high
um
as mentioned there's changes to the
testing in school so we're supporting
the schools around that guidance
with regards to contact tracing so
from our latest update we managed to
reach 81 of our cases in trafford and
we've completed full contact tracing for
75 of those cases so
really really pleased with that aim and
again thank you so much to the residents
for your engagement with that
and finally we continue to spot our our
residents with
self-isolation
so that can be um support accessing
groceries medicine and support around
loneliness and isolation mental health
aim and anything else that you know that
they require the team are working to
support them with that
thank you
thank you catherine can i just say i
think that our contact tracing and
outbreak management to work has been a
particular success and i'd like to just
place on record my thanks to you and
your colleagues
for what's going on and the fact that
we're also going to as helen has said
continue to support schools going
forward um and and so thank you i think
it's been a a real success for us are
there any questions at all
i don't see it thank you very much
catherine can i now uh invite binish to
address us on care homes and supported
accommodation welcome banish
good morning and thank you chair um our
public health and ipc teams uh
commissioners and outbreak team have
been working in partnership with our
care homes and supported accommodation
settings to keep our residents safe
and also to reduce transmission in the
settings with outbreaks to bring the
outbreaks to an end
our data cap capture systems are working
incredibly well and we are supporting
our
settings our care homes and supported
accommodation settings
and responding even more promptly and
efficiently to any issues or
support requests
from our care homes and supported
accommodation settings
january was a challenging month a
challenging time where we had 28
settings and outbreaks
acting in partnership across
multi-disciplinary teams we have managed
to reduce transmission in the settings
and bring
brought outbreaks to an end at present
we have two settings in outbreak
six settings or emerging from an
outbreak and we have managed to bring
seven outbreaks to an end
we have been to provide a forum with our
care homes to answer frequently asked
questions
or
any concerns around testing guidelines
as they stand
so some key points from the testing
guidelines
are
all asymptomatic staff should now test
daily using a rapid lateral flow test
before they
if they are working
whereas all symptomatic residents should
be tested monthly using a pcr test kit
outbreak testing remains the same
if a staff member has returned to work
after testing positive for corvid 19
this should resume lift routine lfd
testing even if this is within 90 days
off the positive cover 19 test
staff testing positive on an lfd within
19 days 90 days or for prior positive
lfd
or pcr test and the result is positive
they should start a new period of
self-isolation
unless a risk assessment suggests that a
re-infection is unlikely
residents uh who test
positive for corvid 19 regardless of the
vaccination status should self-isolate
and then take part in daily rapid
lateral flow tests from day five
um
they can end their self-isolation after
receiving two consecutive negative tests
uh 24 up apart or after 10 days of
isolation
residents who are unable to test should
self-isolate for the full 10 days
following a positive test however
isolation in the residence or this test
to end isolation should only be stopped
when clinical
improvement criterias are met
such as at least some respiratory
recovery there's absence of fever or uh
for uh
for 48 hours without use of medication
and if the individual does not have any
underlying severe immunosuppression
this is the guidance as it stands we are
awaiting further guidance
um and are taking a precautionary
approach thank you
thank you nation again i think this is
another success story for trafford in
the way that we've we've protected our
care homes and i want to place on record
my thanks to to you and and your the
team there for the work that's been done
with care home and and
supported accommodation i have a
question from councillor blackburn
council
yes thank you
um
with with obviously the changes um and
relatives and friends visiting people in
the care homes
are we
expecting
more outbreaks in the future
we are taking a precautionary approach
and with the current measures that we
have in place within our care settings
we
we cannot say at the moment
but the measures that are at present
have worked incredibly well
so that's something that we that would
that we need to see but um
at pres i'll bring him in i think she'd
be able to answer this question much
better thank you helen
thanks bini so um council blackburn i
think it's just to provide assurance
that our care homes have worked
incredibly hard to
protect their staff and and residents
during the pandemic we're continuing to
implement national guidance as is and
we'll be monitoring care home outbreaks
so we can see if there are any increases
and feed that back into the national
system for appropriate response so i
think that's all we can say at the
moment is we're awaiting future guidance
but there will be a huge amount of work
going on at greater manchester level in
terms of
um
future proofing the care homes i suppose
in terms of covid
thank you
thank you helen uh any further questions
at all
denise thank you very much indeed for
coming on this morning and giving us
that update
um let me move on to um to mark jarvis
then mark welcome do you want to add
further on
mass vaccination
no we've we've got a couple of changes
coming up um
so jcvi have approved the offer the
vaccination to five to 11 year olds
um the operational detail is trickling
out
and
it seems likely that they are going
that's going to be offered through
the um national booking sites and the
local pharmacists rather than the gps
um
but as soon as the detail of that has
been worked out then we will share that
with all groups so that people
know how to access those vaccinations
um
we've also as as was mentioned earlier
got the changes with the
boosters to the over 75 cents uh more
vulnerable but we're
waiting for the details
of that
um and will ensure that we have
appropriate services i mean we've worked
hard to
ensure we've had the services available
across the whole the traffic working
with public health for all
our pop-ups for the most vulnerable and
we'll continue to do that
the
current
complication on the horizon is that
all the vaccination center contracts
we're under the covid rules and end on
the 31st of march
so there's gonna have to be some new
arrangements
um to ensure that we can continue to
deliver
vaccinations following that date i'm
sure that
will come through and i'm sure we will
be in a good position to do that
um but it is a detail that we have we
are going to have to work out
so i think that's all i really had to
add today
thank you mark can i just say on the
five to 11 year olds program what sort
of uptake would we expect in trafford
so
nationally
they're talking about
um
lower a fairly low uptake
however
um
if you want to go on holiday with your
children or grandchildren
you have to comply with the local regis
regulations of the country you're going
to rather than our country's
expectations
and a significant number of
um
foreign destinations
are requiring vaccinations even with
that age group and since in trafford we
have a relatively affluent population
who are likely to want to take advantage
of those holidays um i'm expecting us to
have a higher than average uptake of
vaccination in that h group
um but i i've not got to a point of
trying to put any figures on that or the
numbers we are likely to vaccinate at
the moment because of the capacity we
developed for the booster programs
programmes
we know we've got comfortably got
capacity to deliver
what might be required for traffic going
forwards
thank you
can i ask of helen then that going
forward when we know the detail of the 5
to 11 year programme will be advertising
that encouraging um
residents to get their
children vaccinated
i'm going to hand to jilla as she's our
vaccine lead but that's my expectation
jilla
thank you yes absolutely will be
encouraging uptake um i think the
national line on this particular
programme is that it is non-urgent and
we expect there to as mark says be
relatively low uptake because the
balance of costs and benefits of the
vaccine for that age group is uh is
different and
the risks of
covid are that much lower and so the
onus is on parental choice and for us it
will be about enabling access and
ensuring informed choice uh so that
parents can make that choice with full
and accurate information um but uh
certainly we won't be uh
uh
applying pressure the way that we uh
have encouraged very strongly uptake in
the more vulnerable age groups
and i think the other thing to note and
this is something we've observed with
the rollout of the 12 to 15 program
is we've just come through quite a big
spike a wave of omicron and a lot of
children have been infected and were not
eligible because of recent infection
when the
team came into the school so we're also
really encouraging
parents of 12 to 15 year olds who were
not eligible to ensure that they do then
pick up that dose
after waiting 12 weeks from testing
positive and indeed for adults
who tested positive they need to wait 28
days but after that period they should
come forward and get the dose that they
missed
thank you jill and i've got actually one
final question for mark on the
vaccination centers you mentioned about
the leases running out on the 31st of
march what would be expecting then from
uh money from central government to
renew will be part of the deal um
it's one of those unknowns at the moment
i'm afraid um
you it and the same as the um the
monitoring expectations within
healthcare those details are not as yet
available
um however you know the vaccination
program is going to have to happen and
will have to be funded one way or
another
um
because
none of the health service
systems have got the capacity to do it
without that additional
uh funding
um and again you know testing and
monitoring of
of healthcare settings is going to be
different to the rest society
um you will have to develop it's
probably in a similar way to
care home and residential settings but
again at this point in time that
operational detail is not yet available
thank you mark uh any for any questions
from anybody else at all
i don't see any thank you very much can
we move on then to community engagement
and welcome danny danny zamit thank you
thank you jeff
and the team supported the mobile
vaccination unit sessions
by carrying out doorknocking um as well
as opportunity opportunistic engagement
to promote the sessions and there were
many positive interactions resulting
people being vaccinated
and there's also a push to promote
vaccinating clinics this hard term for
the 12 to 15 year olds
and so we share clinic information with
our community champions over email
and valmask representatives as well on
whatsapp and ask them to distribute the
information and this was to complement
the work that we've done with the skills
already and the work of our comms
colleagues as well
and for this program as well we've
offered lots of secondary schools and
various sessions for both people and
families to try and increase the return
of the consent forms for the 12 to 15
programme
and now all of the consent deadlines
have passed so our work with this has
come to an end
and the team started carrying out
sessions in the community to engage with
families
so what we've been doing is using hand
hygiene exercises to instigate
conversations
and this is being supported by
colleagues in our infection prevention
control team as well
and finally
we've given secondary schools and groups
of their students the opportunity to
participate in an arts project
and we'd like each submission to
highlight young people's experiences of
living through the program 19 pandemic
and without
expressions of interest from eight
schools
and so we're looking forward to seeing
how these develop
and when they're coming in june
and then we're looking to do a showcase
event in july
just to um highlight all the work that's
coming from that
thank you
thank you danny and and can i just place
on record again my thanks to the work of
the community engagement team and i
think i've done absolutely sterling work
in in in
encouraging people to get vaccinated
into more more difficult to reach areas
um if you can take that back to the team
i'd be very grateful and thank them um
any questions at all
i don't see any so can i welcome ellie
claddick to talk to us about prom
strategy ellie good morning
hello good morning everyone and yes just
to talk through
um what we've had through from
government which largely reflects um
what helen shared so
obviously with the changes that are
taking place this week and then at the
end of march and there are still a
number of key themes um from the
government in terms of actual advice and
also in terms of messaging so i'll just
go through those quickly again so that
is to get vaccinated um there'll be
another push on it's never too late if
you haven't had your first or your
second it's no longer just about
boosters feel free to come forward um
about the ventilation either meeting
outdoors is still best or ventilate your
home if you're having people indoors
still advise to have a face covering if
you're in indoor busy environments
and stay at home if you're not well and
so that's not just if you have tested
positive curve evaluation if you're just
under the weather
um
test if you are symptomatic um and then
as helen said they catch it bennett kill
it so carry tissues to catch your coughs
and sneezes in um and
hand hygiene so it's all of those things
again and there'll be a particular focus
this side of 31st of march because
obviously and pcr testing continues to
be available to people who do have
symptoms so this side of the 31st of
march the messages will still very much
be if you've got covered symptoms you
can go for a pcr test that is still free
and then longer term the focuses will be
on continuing to wear face coverings and
you know reduces your risk of catching
or spreading covered and to stay at home
um if you're unwell
so as somebody mentioned earlier um you
know the advice and despite
self-isolation being removed is still to
stay at home if you do test positive and
avoid um contact with others
alongside that and there is also an mmr
campaign um that's running nationally to
encourage the takeover of the mmr
vaccine um nationally
and um just to say that we are working
on some designs to
promote the vaccine uptake in terms of a
whole family approach
like reflecting what mark said and
because the um government were talking
about how
i think over a million people's
passports um expired last year and they
probably haven't noticed because they
haven't been on holiday so they think
that there will be quite a significant
backlog so if you try to renew your
passport um fairly close to your holiday
you'll probably do so unsuccessfully so
we're just tying that in um with the
kind of are you ready to go on holiday
messages are you ready in terms of your
vaccine status and um obviously the
helpful message around the passport
um so yeah that's what we've had through
from government and as helen said we're
waiting for um some of this advice and
guidance to sort of be
um boxed out a bit um when the full
guidance comes through and at that point
we'll obviously start
promoting it through more specific
groups and not just to general public in
terms of social media and other
messaging but also to businesses and
schools and any groups might find this
guidance useful
thank you thank you very much ellie
that's a very helpful any questions for
early at all
right i don't cindy thank you for coming
on this morning that's that's very
reassuring um well there's not any other
business uh as i said at the start of
the meeting we're now gonna hold i think
what will be probably our final meeting
of this board on the 16th of march at 10
a.m
if you can put that date in your diary
and hopefully by that time we've had the
full gardens through from the government
and we can really focus
on for that meeting on living with kobe
moving forward in trafford
okay can i thank you all for your
attendance this morning again it's been
very useful and i think a lot of what
we've heard this morning has been
extremely reassuring in light of the
government announcements that were